so let's start with respect what I would
love to see
um after our conversation today is to
see a Ben Shapiro that continues the
growth on Twitter of being even more
respectful than you've already been and
uh maybe one day uh converting That Into
Love on Twitter that would if I could
see that in this world that would make
me die a happy man wow that's a little
bit if I can make that happen for love
in the world for me as a gift for me
I'll try to make that happen I I do have
one question I'm going to need you to
tell me can I like which jokes are okay
are jokes still okay so yeah can I can I
just run your Twitter from now on you
just send it to me I'll pre-screen you
the jokes and you can tell me if this is
a loving joke or if this is a hateful to
be very surprised before by the all the
heart emojis that start popping up on
your Twitter but thank you so much for
being bold and fearless and exploring
ideas and uh your Twitter aside thank
you for being just good faith and all
the arguments and all the conversations
you're having with people it's a huge
honor thank you for talking to me thanks
for having me I really appreciate it